[Música]
después de varios meses sin tocar debido
al confinamiento obligatorio por la
pandemia la banda boliviana gustavo
orihuela quartet vuelve a un escenario
aunque lo hace en un teatro adaptado
para transmisiones en directo y sin
butacas estamos súper contentos
volvamos al escenario aunque no sea con
el contacto directo con la gente si bien
esta nueva modalidad virtual nos permite
estar nosotros para pagarnos un poco más
no podemos llegar a varios países el
teatro nuna ha invertido para innovar en
la tecnología y la capacitación de su
personal para las emisiones en streaming
nosotros queremos realmente simular lo
que es venir al teatro lo que era venir
al teatro antes de la pandemia que es
vivir las obras en tiempo presente y el
tiempo presente
es algo que permite ver la capacidad del
artista de
improvisar desde su casa la periodista
isabel nadie lamenta perderse la
experiencia en vivo pero asegura que ha
sido compensada por la calidad de la
transmisión
el tiempo que esta banda le ha gustado
se ha tomado para
y lanzarse de nuevo en este otro formato
les ha servido porque está su primera
actuación desde el una en él
en streaming me ha parecido que ha sido
muy bien lograda
en tiempos de pandemia no podemos ir al
teatro pero la música viene a nuestra
casa para que sigamos consumiendo
cultura y así será por mucho tiempo en
bolivia porque continúan prohibidos los
espectáculos públicos